[Music]
for their latest turn began earlier this
month and it's going to be one to watch
unfortunately we won't actually be able
to watch any of its because the Supreme
Court does not allow cameras during oral
arguments and all that Justice Scalia
explained why if I really thought it
would educate the American people I
would be all for it but what most of the
American people would see would be
30-second 15-second takeouts from our
argument and those takeouts would not be
characteristic of what we do you know he
might be right about that
television can be very irresponsible
which is why you never want to for
instance do an interview in front of a
blue screen because someone might then
superimpose a creepy orgy behind you the
point is there aren't any cameras but
they do release audio recordings of
their arguments so TV does play
15-second clips of the Supreme Court
anyway it's just that they have to
present it like this suppose a state
said because we think that the focus of
marriage really should be on procreation
we're not going to give marriage
licenses anymore to any couple where
both people are over the age of 55 would
that be constitutional okay first start
that is a terrible rendering of Justice
Kagan you just made her look like Jonah
Hill in a wig also it was boring and
that's a problem because what happens at
the Supreme Court is way too important
not to pay attention to and yet the ban
renders any coverage basically
unwatchable but I think we may have a
solution and it's learning a lesson from
this
[Music]
think about it if someone made you just
listen to the audio of that you would
punch them repeatedly in the face but
the visual makes it irresistible why
because a cat's paws are doing things
you wouldn't expect them to do and if it
works for shitty piano music it can work
for the Supreme Court and that is why
this week we spent an incredible amount
of time and an almost immoral amount of
resources to produce an entire Supreme
Court settle down let me show you this
puppy in action one of the current cases
in the court is Holt versus Hobbes it's
about whether a prison can require a
Muslim inmate to trim his beard for
security reasons now you might be
thinking John I do not want to hear a
discussion about that really don't you
let's assume I'm in a religion that
requires polygamy
[Applause]
okay I won't have three watch just let
me have two wives
I mean you still have in your religion
it seems to me if he allows it is feared
to be clipped to one one one inches
well it is the state's burden that is
explicit on statute you know the only
limit to impose on the hair on top of
your head as I can't explain below the
middle there now give us me a carrot top
your head in the hair in the front of
your head is it's not even rational be
honest you not want to hear the entire
hour long but I will give me just
another taste
as far as searching a beer dispenser why
can't the prison just give the inmate a
comb you could develop whatever you want
I'm saying comb your beard and if
there's anything in their faces SIM card
in there or a revolver or anything else
you think
can be hidden in a half-inch beard tiny
revolver it'll fall out those dry
constitutional arguments are now
must-see television and that is why
tonight as a public service we are
releasing raw video at this address of
close-ups medium shots and wide shots
from our real animals fake positive
wrinkles and we are inviting all news
networks to use this footage to make
Supreme Court arguments more compelling
to watch we have all nine justices for
you
Chief Justice Roberts this Scalia
Kennedy Thomas Ginsburg Breyer Alito
Sotomayor and Kagan who I will warn you
would not sit still for full coverage
you need Justice Alito taking notes done
not a problem
you need Ginsburg adjusting her glasses
you need something without having a
drink of water you need Roberts your
knee bill your toilet you need at least
a covering disease with this port or
banging a gavel or humping Eleanor Kagan
[Applause]
amazing plus plus we have two lawyers
for you to choose from also a duck
assistant and a court stenographer who's
just doing the best she can to keep up
the entire toolkit is here for anyone to
do with as they please and if there are
not full reenactments of every major
court case of the past four years online
by next Sunday you will never see us
here again
you